Simon how do you arrive at these figures
15 billion in costs and potentially up
to 40 billion euros in extra capital
requirements yes what we did was
actually interviewed our end customers
because it's really important to hear
from the corporates so we spoke to SMEs
in Europe we spoke to the larger
companies 62 in total and we said what
are the major concerns about brexit and
they have major concerns but then we
looked at it from a banking point of
view and said well what will the cost be
of having to restructure and the 15
billion is related to the ring-fencing
costs you remember from the UK and the
40 billion is raised to the capital that
might have to move from the UK to Europe
so big numbers but we did take a hard
brick set as our proposition and of
course we don't know yet what's gonna
happen and suggest you put this pushes
that cost for business because the cost
of capital is pushed I'm absolutely
right and if you're an SME you probably
have one bank that you rely on you
probably can't change your bank that
ease thee you probably have fewer
resources so I think the SMEs are really
saying hang on this is a serious problem
for us and actually of course the
timeframe is quite narrow so I think the
message and report amongst others is
let's make sure we have understanding as
to how this all works
now you mentioned there this is a hard
brexit scenario I'm realistically
speaking we're not going to get that are
we not when Michele Barnea who's leading
the European Commission's negotiating
team has said that a specific deal was
going to need to be done for the city
said this could be later on in the
process and what customers want is
certainty and I think we might find is
the whole kind of discussion around
transition and implementation waits
until the end and that's too late
so the message we're saying is planned
for the worst but hope for the best
absolu then there are these separate
developments today the City of London
representatives from the city going
directly to Brussels
ostensibly with tacit government support
do you think this is being driven by the
Treasury because the Treasury is more
Pro financial services and other parts
of the government
I'd love to reveal the inside track
owners but I can't because I just read
what you've read but I think what's
interesting is mark Hoban the former
City Minister very well-respected I
think it makes a lot of sense for him to
be in dialogue with Brussels one of our
lessons really learnt from brexit is
that there's a potential for
misunderstanding so if Mark is out
talking to the people in Brussels that's
great I think what's really important is
let's be coordinated though about the
efforts across
the industry well quite I mean this is
gonna put the cat among the pigeons I
mean the carmaker's presumably will turn
around and say well hang on if the
city's allowed to cut a special deal
with Brussels shouldn't we be allowed to
Scotland Nicola Sturgeon wants to stay
in the single market I mean that's an
issue for all industries are it
important but this is a 15 percent of
GDP industry two million people employed
in the UK obviously we're pan-european
you can increase those numbers
significantly for euros I think it is
right there's a focus on this industry
but it's also right that we look at it
through the end customer piece as well I
mean your team spend an awful lot of
time in Brussels Deere do you think
there's a desire to make sure that the
city is looked after I mean after all
the city services the whole of the EU
and provides value for them as well it's
not just a British thing well think of
how much capital markets activity comes
through London so I think the reality is
that if London gets completely detached
from Europe capital markets activity in
Europe is there gonna be effects as well
which is another message from this
report the big challenge for Europe is
economic growth a fragmented capital
market means less economic growth so
there's a sort of opportunity to have a
win-win here I think so you ran Gordon
Brown's Downing Street press off
operation for a while I mean if you were
director of comms in number 10 now what
would you be saying about all this I
think I'd be saying we've got to be very
transparent this is a negotiation which
is going to be played out in public
it's the biggest divorce in history and
I think what's really important is that
the government here and the EU explain
what's happening is how it's happening
that sounds as though that's difficult
to achieve but I think that dyers being
cast so effective communication about
what's happening when it's happening how
it's happening is really important for
the long-term success of brexit and the
clock is ticking I reckon we've got 10
and negotiating months to get this done
10 months if you take out some holidays
and the rest of it 10 months probably to
get a deal settled so that's why an
implementation period at the end of that
is so important the clock is ticking so
I'm a Louis good to see you thanks for
joining me